un parcours de 51 km sur des sentiers de
randonnée entre le château de Versailles
et le Château de Rambouillet le tracé a
été imaginé par les organisateurs du
premier trail des villes royales un
programme inédit dans les ivelines on
voulait organiser une course qui était
longue euh qui était en Île-de-France en
hiver alors qu'il n'y en a pas encore et
l'idée de promouvoir un petit peu le
tourisme le patrimoine de la région
entre le château de Versailles Château
de rbouillet est venu il y a 9 mois et 9
mois après comme acccouchement on est
sur la ligne de départ les sportifs
avaient la possibilité de courir
l'intégralité de la course seul ou en
équipe de tris avec un passage de témoin
à chevreose et au Fargis c'est à la mode
maintenant il y en a beaucoup donc il
faut savoir trouver ça va être original
pour pour attirer du monde il trouve que
c'est très original pour cette grande
première plus de 1000 coururs venus des
Yvelines de la région Île-de-France de
Suisse et de Belgique ont mis leur
basket pour participer à ce rendez-vous
nous sommes venus en en équipe nous
avons quatre relais mix relais voilà et
on va essayer de se comment dirais-je de
se donner un petit peu le un petit peu
de tirer la Bour je dirais on fera pas
de podium c'est surtout le c'est une
sortie comment dirais-je une sortie
genre sortie d'entraînement où on se va
se donner un petit peu quand même au
niveau des résultats Nicolas duil a
terminé la course individuelle en 3h47
dans la catégorie relais la team PDM a
bouclé le périple en 3h49 une deuxè
édition devrait être organisé l'année
prochaine